[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i remember we went to uh this thing
called beta breakers a while back there
and it was like this it was a race i
guess where people start i guess at the
bay and then they run like the bridge or
something yep well we did a bunch of
mushrooms and we didn't uh
i don't know we weren't really in the
race or anything but at one point we
took over
a
a table somebody had a table where they
had all the cups of water and we took it
over right in the middle and i'm just
just flying on mushrooms at this point
dude i mean i'm look you know the lord's
looking for me you know when i'm looking
for him you know we're gonna meet up
that afternoon
but uh and people are running by in this
race you know it's tens of thousands of
people in this race and when they get
close someone would would try to get the
water and be like no it's for asian
people only
so you had so many people and they're
running they have to keep going there's
there's a huge flow of people they can't
argue or discuss it right right he'd be
like uh notation's holding it like
and just keep on like passing out from
dehydration a quarter mile down the road
all these irish people stacking up at
the curb at the next turn just from boom
and asian people were so happy yeah just
flying bro
it was so bizarre though we get naked
and they both just start cackling oh wow
with laughter when they see my body
but i'm laughing too right but i did it
anyway but the whole time why you never
you've seen your body before they've
never seen my body though right but what
are you laughing at because they're
laughing at my body oh okay they're
laughing so hard it makes me want to
laugh i think you're waiting your whole
life to see your body and this is when
you decided to do it
[Laughter]
no no that's not it
i had seen my body do i have mirrors
yeah but you could also not see your
body if you want like i'll go sometimes
you know i remember one time i went like
eight months without seeing my legs i
never called him dad from the age of
five to ten we lived together it was it
was dark he always looked at me like
he'd like if he could yeah like if he
could he would
he would [ __ ] murder me but you were
probably ready to take him on it too
where you know i was terrified you're
trying to commit suicide i tried to uh
od on a bottle of thera grand m you know
what is that
vitamins yeah i try to odd vitamins
would you get just better i just fell
asleep
[Laughter]
they didn't have oxycontins back there
oh thank god in the podcasting world
that i would that you feel like you
would have to shut up with not shack up
jesus christ that's respect for yourself
who would that man like who is the man
is it a brendan shaw type of guy would
you then you think have to gravitate
towards like
this like
burlesque kind of like um
ambient sound of a man gun to my head
because i would not date a single comic
for the rest of my life
and that's a fact look i could get a new
job
i could easily
open
[Laughter]
how far you can't water a plant or
anything can you no i the times that
i've squirted like i've i've scored it
twice it was more of like a spill yeah
like it's just all of a sudden you're
like oh what the hell oh wow the
government's gonna have to clean this up
you know
a lot of [ __ ] people are gonna
[ __ ] fill out insurance claims
but it's [ __ ] someone call fema like
how much like enough to like dampen a
small burger like enough to ruin a small
burger
like how much are we talking god damn it
theo that is exactly the right amount oh
no i would say half a juice box for me
yeah which is enough to dampen a burger
for sure
what is this reaction
oh i got mixed reactions about it in
elementary school i lived in minnesota
and the kids used to
throw not snowballs at my head but ice
rocks oh wow
and they just used as hard as they can
just throw it at my [ __ ] hat why you
collected them or something no i don't
no one collects ice rocks like oh people
are being mean
he will be mean [ __ ] my bad man you
think i had an icicle collection at my
home you said you were the weird guy
i could see you collecting and people
were like hey here's another one
and he threw it on my head yeah and it
hits my head and i go thanks
well this one's shaped like rosie
o'donnell
no dude
no they used to do it violently
i'm sorry man i just want to be free
also to say what i want to say like last
night on the stage joey diaz had a stage
a joke that had a bunch of racial slurs
in it right yeah ones that we would all
not even probably say on this podcast
except you because you work with a lot
of black people you might be willing to
drop oh i don't do the n word huh i
don't do the answer oh i don't do it
dude unless you do yeah
you
know i'm just joking yeah i mean i quit
doing it probably about four years ago
when everybody else did really yeah you
got off i mean yeah i was like i like
how you quit porn after this
this train is going nowhere because i
started going with like a therapist when
i was like 23. yeah so
i've been i just stopped you're like the
larry fitzgerald of therapy i feel like
yeah man i got dreads and [ __ ] and we
have to make urban references you're the
blackest guy we've had on the show
man he actually sent me
he actually was like neal man can you go
over and [ __ ] uh he said bless bless
theo so you know he's black um uh so
i used to have those buzzer underwear
bro they put these underwear on you when
the urine would hit them a buzzer would
go off oh my god
i'm not joking look him up online this
ain't no joke bro so i went to my
grandparents my mother didn't tell him
that i had these right i'm really hoping
these are a real thing and not just a
like a torture device your parents put
on not at all they made by themselves
this doctor gave them to us dude this
dude was a bunch of google it was a bona
fide doctor
so we went there i got the electric
pants on dude you know
wait wait would you like google i'm
getting my rest probably you know buzzer
underwear for urinators
google buzzer underwear for urinators um
and uh so then
but they didn't tell my grandfather
right
so he [ __ ] had a small house bro a
little bitty house
so my [ __ ] crotch is just but like he
he wakes up middle of the night dude
you're on fire
i'm not on fire but i'm buzzing hard bro
because i'd had apple juice man and i
pissed big on apple juice dude i [ __ ]
spray out on the aj
so i'm in there just buzzing dude i
didn't know god and he came in he still
got him
yeah give me a penalty
he didn't know what was going on oh my
god that's what he comes in he's scared
how loud is this in a little bitty house
you could uh you could hear from down i
just want to wake my wife up in the
middle of that like twice a week
i would just do two drops and you and it
goes off
and uh
and so my grandfather's in there right
and he's all scared and [ __ ] and uh oh
this would have been terrible when i was
a kid and he's pushing me with a
broomstick dude he thought i was dead
dude he didn't know what had happened
and we thought i was possessed or dead
he's pushing me with a broomstick to
wake me up and he was worried because he
had one of those heart makers
and uh he was worried he would get
electrocuted he thought something was
happening he thought the house had
short-circuited it or the phone company
had [ __ ] up that's what he thought the
phone company had [ __ ] up
so he thinks i'm [ __ ] just laying
there buzzing like there's a [ __ ]
miscreant
but he died man my grandfather
oh i never have treated animals
differently whether male or female oh
but i get i remember asking like i'll
ask like a waiter like yeah is this fish
male or female sometimes if i order like
a sat a salmon or something
you know that's a good one just to kind
of see you know and a lot of times
they'll go check
and sometimes they'll come back with an
answer that's amazing it's like ugh i
guess there's no you know what i would
love in that scenario is when they came
back with an answer you just go wrong
and get up and walk out because you know
they're trying to pull someone
wrong yeah and open something up with a
knife just show them a part of the fish
what is that he told me that that's a
fish dick yeah you [ __ ] tell me that
hide something in there
jesus now you know what a fish stick
looks like you thought that you know the
sky was just gray
and then you turn up put on no you
imagine putting your poke and then
they're blue
you see colors where then they'll go oh
wow
they'll go
no no no no
no no put out the glasses of the glasses
you only see black and white right now
yeah you see black and white right now
right well you you'd be his like wife
and like give it right and here you go
here you go um grandpa phillips
right
yeah
and then they'll do that yeah
and they'll start crying
okay
okay
i don't know what you're doing right now
i think he's acting yeah yeah falling
asleep
yeah yeah
dude and it happens to a lot of senior
citizens well no uh
address somebody with a mental illness
okay i just say this you [ __ ] idiot
you [ __ ] [ __ ] bro don't make me take
half to see alice right now all right
i'm going to say this right now okay
yeah colorblind you're born with it yeah
are you their whole life maybe it's
maybelline
so their whole
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
listen to me right now george laughs
dude all right he's from another country
he's from idaho
right so they can't see that he was he
could have lied colorblind they're they
have it their whole lives who
just people that are colorblind not
anyone specific
yeah i think if people are colorblind i
think we got
we got to get them more colors i've
never ever pictured you in a sexual way
like some cause when i meet anyone
when i look at everyone what do you
picture me doing
i i picture you fishing somebody told me
the other day that they
i always they i remind them of
lieutenant dan but if he still had legs
and i remember her mom was out of town
or something we 69
in her mom's closet oh my and i remember
i remember her abs i smell the shoes too
i love being in somebody's mom's closet
you can smell their [ __ ] nice high
heels and stuff in there
it wasn't a memory that was lodged into
my head okay okay but i do remember is
it cold in there kind of
that's another another thing another
experience that i don't recall okay okay
but i remember grabbing her cheeks
and you know you're 16 i'm always the
bottom i never do top really yeah yeah
yeah yeah because then you have your
mouth [ __ ] her i don't like any guy
who goes upstairs on a 69 bro yeah yeah
yeah i don't think i've ever seen that
you're right it's always the bottom my
bad that's insane it's insane bro the
guy goes upstairs
dude it is so nice though when i'm
walking around in my head is having a
fun time yeah
that's the [ __ ] singing
yeah hearing associations thinking about
something making
a black guy like a big black guy big
giant black guy at the gym you don't
even know why you fist bumps but he
liked it you just you liked it he liked
it maybe he knows you maybe he doesn't
maybe he just felt you yeah you're
walking off you're like i didn't do
slavery i'm good yeah i'm straight yeah
just regular white people thoughts
when i need to think about something
good did i think about lee man
well thank you that means a lot yeah i
think about you man i think you think
about you to laugh you i mean just this
stuff you say randomly like i just want
to hang out and like
listen to what you say during the day to
yourself i just i feel like it's
hysterical this conversation is getting
creepy right here already
well you just farted on me i think we
out of the closet pretty soon they say
hey you know the boy over there a little
little longer give a [ __ ]
i don't care either bruh i'll let you
hang off my dick like a [ __ ] mountain
cave oh i would never let lisa not you
guys but i don't have the same
relationship with him yeah but you're
still friends you can't i'm friends with
him i wouldn't [ __ ] him i'll let him
touch my dick a little you know saying
down around the holidays bro just to
make his day oh he's a prison ham this
guy bro i [ __ ] love that boy you know
how much money i told
we won't walk and leave one night
how much money we can make with lee on
the inside oh my god just sitting on
people's laps dealing cards rubbing
their dick yeah just whatever bringing
this back you can't just sit on
someone's lap but they're not going to
let it end just like sitting bro
they're not in prison because they they
gary indiana you're an eight bro a warm
female and gary indiana dog you're a
female hey baby man i got a guy that'll
pay 10 gs for you to put a wig on
oh yeah special type of podcast and just
mug his dick with your [ __ ] neck he's
already ripped me a letter what does
that even mean
there's not that story that the
strongest slave changed it all it's the
thinker slave it's the frederick doug
you know it's or it's the leaders it's
the
it's yeah it's the thinkers yeah it's
the thinkers and the feelers and and and
that in the connectors right
you know because that's the
the the reality it's not like
slavodactyl you know the strongest you
know what i'm saying like even though
it'd be a great superhero guy who came
in and just changed it all
you know you mean like a pterodactyl
slave i mean i'm not talking about a
slave that [ __ ] a bird but i'm talking
about like a slave that
you know i've just picked a bad name i
mean like an iron man if you give them
free time they'll start [ __ ] birds
women's clitorises are penises that
aren't fully formed so when you're in in
utero or whatever you're
trying to form dude one girl i remember
he's like thumb wrestling down there
exactly i mean this thing was really
sometimes girls have huge clothes oh and
two against this thing when i was trying
to touch this lady's vagina dude
this clitoris definitely seemed like it
[ __ ] could have worn you know part of
a mitten this thing was grande
you know
yeah because she probably has more
testosterone yeah
she was title nine definitely you know
she had that [ __ ] title nine [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
virgin power is so strong bro
oh dude that's crazy oh a uh somebody
parked a volkswagen rabbit on this guy's
leg one time outside of our school house
and i saw a virgin [ __ ]
lift it right off his leg wild
yo and this was in [ __ ] who knows
when it was every scene is from like the
movie powder
every scene it's amazing what are you
talking about every scene if you're live
stories like that i've never seen a
virgin pick up a car yeah they pick up
ak-47s now that's the problem
virgins now are picking up ar-15s
hopefully they start picking up cars
again that would be nice they need to
grab some [ __ ] then bruh i agree with
you because they're shutting down all
the [ __ ] bruh that's who's doing it if
the audience gave me a hundred dollars
right mm-hmm i was gonna urinate in one
of the speakers on stage right what yeah
how were you [ __ ] up i mean i was
having a few cocktails okay so this is
like when you're
just part drinking yeah
so we only got to about 80 right so
anyway i got off stage i'm outside
there's some people like saying hey dude
we're going to this uh we're going to a
piles party something you want to come
and i was like only if my boy can come
and i'll look over and they had an urban
guy you know and like a louis vuitton
kind of jacket
like kind of like a black urban guy okay
and so i suddenly if my boy can come and
i point it at him or i don't even know
this guy okay
and uh
and they're like that's your boy and i'm
like yup that's my boy
so next you know we're on a limo this
guy happens to be homeless right or not
or doesn't know where his home is right
more that kind of guy
so anyway we're all going to this party
and i walked right over to him as soon
as they said yeah he can come i walked
over and i was like hey dude
you ever been in a limo he's like no i'm
like you're coming with me just no
matter what pretend you were my best
friend that's it and was he good at that
bro so good at it right we get in the
car people that can't take that
direction they don't know what to do he
immediately dude was like oh yeah he
started naming people he actually was a
little too good right right he was like
oh yeah you you remember on wallace
and i'm like
nobody
[Laughter]
but anyway we get to the party we go in
the house it's like this kind of fancy
party a lot of people there have been
like maybe at a wedding or something and
uh we're there like four minutes i hear
people scream from upstairs and hear a
window break
this guy went into the coat room stole a
bunch of purses jumped out the window
and [ __ ] boy
holy
[ __ ] that's pretty crazy
that was pretty crazy and i was like man
when i did losers changed a lot in
africa they hit you with a [ __ ] pipe
bro if they love you just take a win for
that fight i'm gonna take a whiff of
your fart that's come on get a little
air appetizer bruh treat your nose that
is tremendous treat your snout to some
of that [ __ ] free booty pasta bruh
bruh
it was tough for my mom she had to raise
three kids he left he left the country
went back to mexico
left left his credit card debt of course
he did he left it and everything and it
[ __ ] my mom up financed she was making
150 a week so she was always working
overtime she worked hard my mom my mom
worked [ __ ] hard for us and on
fridays no matter what on fridays we're
going to mcdonald's really yeah and we
were like hell yeah that was like do you
remember what you got [ __ ] this is the
same my mom would take a little fish
baby
[ __ ]
yeah i love that
yeah
i still eat those that's still my
dessert like if i want to cheat if i'm
going to cheat i'm going to go get that
filet-o-fish
are you kidding me what [ __ ] [ __ ]
kid yeah gets the fish dude i don't even
know we could order the fish i was like
30 years old
i thought you had to be like a real
adult
because that was my mom's [ __ ] my mom
got the philadelphia show so i got into
it too
and it would stay there unbothered and a
little baggy waterproof in case the
[ __ ] rain came guess the floods came
in case you got biblical yeah yeah this
don't break out of it yeah i still in
case louisiana all over again i'm gonna
tie a float and waving at the airport
[ __ ] i'm here
dude how great with evie you're on the
news they're like showing you you're
just down there doing coke and they're
like waving at the helicopters
like how many videos are there of the
news during a katrina where there's just
a bunch of brothers just blowing a
[ __ ] blunt and they [ __ ] couldn't
put it on
and just yelling up you can't stop me
bitching
i was the first one i had to quit my job
full time so i kind of got like i was
like guys are we doing this because i
gotta give up on giggle like i had to
quit giggle everybody else was able to
work both jobs q was still a fireman sal
still owned his it was still bartender
in the let's say look still a fireman is
a unique term as well i'm not saying i
love firemen right yeah especially if
there's a fire going on
the number one person you want to see
but there's not a fire dude they're
basically people that are training for
the hot dog eating coffee that's exactly
right yeah yeah yeah but you know good
people at heart is awful that's what
they're professional softballs
what are you gonna be you're bobby lee
man you're not gonna be somebody else
yeah you kind of want to be bruce lee or
something something like guy like that
no dude you're way more bruce lee fought
you're like not a fighter you're true
but i could fight
dude you are i could fight who's that
here's a guy right here a little white
kid that'll fight you dude
hey bobby
hey i've seen uh fear he's been doing
bjj lately what are the chances that you
join in whenever you're allowed out the
house again
and um how long do you think it's gonna
be until you do comedy
he said
you can fight can you fight
i didn't understand what he was saying
though yes
this is what i heard
dude that's charles dickens bro okay
i don't even know who that is is that
the guy i think i've heard of him great
grandson yeah chuck
now with your mom being so tough was it
like did was it tough to feel like
affection from her because sometimes
like my mom's a hard worker right my mom
delivered you know she's a delivery
woman you know she delivered newspapers
when i was a kid she delivers magazines
now um
she's always had a [ __ ] van you know
now she's got my her husband he's that's
alzheimer's don't even know he's in the
van he's with her every day just [ __ ]
bouncing around in the [ __ ] passenger
seat
she had to get a [ __ ] second seatbelt
installed for him because he [ __ ]
would kind of slit he's getting little
he would slip out of the [ __ ] first
one and now she's got him just
basically in a [ __ ] straight jacket
just bouncing around he has no clue
where he is
just delivering [ __ ] news on wheels
every day you know i think he's about 90
you know your mom still does this my mom
still does it dude and here's the worst
part about she got a good deal on this
van right my mom likes a good deal and
she got a good deal on this van has no
win none of the side or back windows bro
so
her [ __ ] gps is the lord brussels she
just [ __ ] bouncing around he's got
him in the thing one of the roads there
was somebody doing magic or pretending
they were doing magic but really they
were just trying to touch each you know
just trying to get a little bit of touch
you know a little bit of david david
coppin feels you know what i'm saying oh
come back here i'm gonna pull a rabbit
out this hat but then you get back there
and the only thing in that hat is you
know a little bit of regular [ __ ]
you're like oh this this ain't a rabbit
this ain't a rabbit you know but i'ma
let that thing hop around on me
yeah people think if they eat a mac
nugget that it's against gays out here
you know dude i have four or five mac
nuggets and not even thinking about a
man i i'll go get some mcnuggets and
then go to an anti-gay protest
it doesn't stop me oh yeah
oh that's interesting this is the
camaraderie you know it's not even what
i believe it's just like cool dudes
hanging out having fun dude sometimes
i've
i wonder if do you ever feel like a lot
of gay men
gay men get seem to me also to be very
judgmental a lot of times here and maybe
i just see that in los angeles and maybe
it's something that just i feel but i
feel like
it's not i feel like gay men don't
really support men that much really they
support other gay men it seems like
but i don't know if they support a show
on like on like one of the gay bars in
santa monica boulevard yeah um
i mean listen most gay men are fine but
the queens are the worst audience
because like shot app you don't know you
listen to half your setups i'm like wait
what and you're like you didn't even pay
attention to any of this yeah shut the
[ __ ] up they just sometimes come in to
raise hell and they sometimes act like
the crosswalk is a model area for
modeling you know that that lady who
dances no yeah well i see a guy he
[ __ ] just he's not doing anything but
crossing the street all night and you
know just flat you know bragging about
how he's infinity boots and john elliott
pants i've had several people bring
with them
to see me and they will bring the
sonogram of the ultrasound that they had
taken and get you to autograph it or
something no i would hold it up they
would be sitting here and i would hold
it up and we'd be smiling and i would
kind of point at it yeah yeah and people
think you're the dad no no no no they
don't i don't think they think that but
anyway i would look dude if santa was my
dad you know excited
people were like what does your dad do
like uh he works at the bank i'm like oh
my dad santa
my dad's santa wow that's pretty magical
this one girl i knew like she there was
so much squirting sometimes like i would
like check to see if she was okay like
it was like i was like it was almost
biblical you know a couple of chapters
of it it was just like this is
you know i felt bad like the cat would
come around because he thought i'd cut
the faucet on like just kind of like
crazy [ __ ] dude and you had to change
all the [ __ ] like at a certain point
like i'm sorry if you're nice if you're
a squirter and you know that you are
one of the guys together uh they put me
on zoloft because they they too how
great was it in the beginning amazing
bro i could drink nine gin and tonics
dude and not get drunk
i liked it uh i liked it for like a
decade though oh wow that was good i
didn't it wasn't a drinking thing for me
i just liked i liked it oh yeah i loved
it bro i could get up early i felt good
you would you last longer when you had
sex oh i wasn't i'd last longer when i
jerked off for sure sure all right same
thing
definitely uh way definitely dude yeah
uh because you were always looking to
last longer
yeah yeah right yeah you wanted to save
it oh no i did i'm definitely at a
certain point it's like jesus
come on man what was this for yeah
i'm the one who's i'm gonna have the
orgasm what are we making it last for uh
it's like my uh what's that greek guy
who's pushing the ball up the hill
yeah it's like this is mine yeah like
yeah why am i yeah uh where you're
looking for just the right thing to
finish like what just finish
dude i could press my butthole against
the corner of the counter right when i
go
is that true yeah i believe that because
you couldn't make it i was young bro
when i was young yeah great like the r
kelly [ __ ] is coming out again now
because he's broke so he can't pay
people off
oh wow yeah it's like imagine how yes
how stressful that must have been though
just juggling all the pedophiophilia
stuff
you know
just
busting around the [ __ ]
warming the urine constantly and busting
it around
you know like
he didn't like to produce new york
and age oh i better be sure he did he
seems like a guy that likes an aged nice
age jared oh yeah it's dark isn't it
yeah but it is what it is it's funny
though it is funny and you know in
indiana i think the klu klux klan
started there and a lot of people think
it was in the south and it was actually
in indiana so you know i'm just kind of
saying that uh
but you know other good stuff started
there too basketball
so one thing that was good for different
ethnicities and one thing that was bad
for different ethnicities so it's you
know it's definitely hit or miss out
there you know it's hit or miss there's
no way i could ever have sex with like
one of these dudes that are like giving
me money for like you know enjoying
lurking
yeah yeah so i was like there's no way
and nick does it a lot
the producer actually
that's false
he seems like somebody that does then
sorry that's fair dude my little nephew
used to hide on top of [ __ ] like on
bookshelves and [ __ ] and be real quiet
and [ __ ] surprise you bro yeah yeah
he was like 19 months old i'm like
that's insane
there's no way he got up there by
natural cause no
you could tell he definitely been like
envisioned and being up on that shelf
and he just woke up there one morning
you know this ain't no free solo baby
right here it's all about the angle he's
like yeah i'm gonna do the most damage
come down strong oh yeah dude he was
really yeah some of these children
they're just wild they got the egg
around and po in them you know
something's going on they got dirty
birds in the back of their
dude i remember making love to this girl
one time or not even making love but
trying to
and um
and her mom came home right this and
this is like the first time i was ever
like just started having sex you know
when i was young and her mom came home
opened the door and we're in her bed
right
and i had to go and i was just like you
know i'm always pretty affable with
parents i just walked over and just
[ __ ] introduced myself it was just so
[ __ ] awkward i got busted when i was
14.
my girlfriend at the time were having
sex and her dad came home and i just
jumped in the closet naked with condom
on and just hiding in the closet shaking
waiting for him to leave and he took so
long for him to leave by the time he
left i passed out
in the closet and my dick was like super
small and still had the condom just like
barely hanging off
um that's all that was that was one of
the funnest things i liked about being
young was sneaking around and [ __ ] or
like i used to steal kids bikes that
would leave their like i would ride like
a little girl's bike over to like this
girlfriend i was dating her house was
like four miles away and i would sneak
in in the middle of the night and she
had these loud cats that had to sleep in
a room like her parents made all the
cats stay in her bedroom at night with
her right
so i'd be in there try to like go down
on them there'd be like nine cats in
this [ __ ] living room dude i can jump
into my back and [ __ ] licking my feet
and stuff dude a van is just a trap
house on wheels
anything could have dude if somebody had
a car it was like oh things was limited
you know you could ride around you could
listen to some music you could put some
beers in a trunk you could smoke a joint
right somebody had a [ __ ]
van
dude if your friend had a van bruh
anything could happen you could start a
small business you could run a butcher
shop in the back of that [ __ ] son
you know what i'm saying y'all doing 40
miles an hour and [ __ ] dropping bacon
bits out the back
in a van anything could happen in a van
if you was girls you was a couple of bad
[ __ ] rolling out you know
put in your [ __ ] you know put in a
real you know put your strongest tampon
in and hit the town
we doing it tonight
daniella
you know
you know what i'm saying
maria you know what i'm saying huh
huh susan huh tiffany
tonight we letting it all hang out
no bra tonight girl
i'm letting these titties touch the wind
and i don't know if this is probably
this might be gay or not and i might i
don't think i'm gay but what have you
heard you know yeah but what i'm saying
is this do you think having a guy give
you a blow job would probably be pretty
intense bro because dudes you're seeing
a dude eat something real fast they're
pretty quick
plus just physically their throat is
longer they have bigger heads oh it's
kind of scaring me you get an extra like
quarter inch oh i need that soft blow
job i need that lady blow job yeah but
are there tongues like like i'm sure
gruffer you know oh yeah
yeah think about it bro
sometimes you could if you accidentally
put two uh kitkats in your mouth you
could separate them with your tongue in
your mouth yeah girls can't do that no
no
and have a friend help break them
[Music]
ain't no
just the wrong way i know
[Music]